you know on this on this issue of the
crazy sexual politics
there is a truly disturbing story just
came out of iowa
there was a little girl in iowa whose
parents
were nerd wells and so she was going to
be adopted by her great-grandparents
this one-year-old girl
so her great grandparents had to apply
to the state just to make sure this
paperwork worked because
the kid's parents were not able to take
care of her
the united states
district judge reversed this decision
to allow the great grandparents to take
care of her holding that the state
regula
so so i'm sorry let me rewind you've got
the kid who's going
to the state the foster system
the great great the great grandparents
try to adopt the kid it's a little bit
confusing
then the state comes in and says no you
can't adopt the kid
because you have oppressive sexual views
here are some of the questions that they
had to answer
according to the political correct
orthodoxy if they wanted to adopt their
great-granddaughter
how would we react if the daughter was a
lesbian
would we allow the daughter to have a
girl spend the night at our home
as our girl's romantic partner if at 15
years old
this little girl wanted to undergo
hormone therapy to change her sexual
appearance
would we support that decision and
transport her for those treatments
if as a teenager this little girl wanted
to dress as a boy and be called a boy's
name would we accept her decision
and allow her to act in that manner
if you don't say that you are willing to
let your
adopted daughter have her lesbian
girlfriend come and sleep over at age 15
if you don't say that you will allow
your adopted daughter to
inject hormones into herself to appear
cosmetically more like a boy
now according to the idaho
department of health and welfare you're
not allowed to adopt that daughter
goodness gracious thankfully as i as i
mentioned another government agency came
in namely that
the judiciary actually came in and
reversed that decision for now
for now how long before this is
replicated all over the country
idaho i thought it was a pretty
conservative place i mean imagine
you know when i was a kid if i was 15
and i said hey mom i want my girlfriend
to spend the night
she would have smacked me [ __ ] are you
kidding me but now
now this is a human right i guess you're
not allowed to adopt i hope you enjoyed
that short segment from the michael
knowles show be sure to check out the
full episode linked in the description
or download the podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
you